hello and welcome to this video lilo 81
early one day I would submit attraction
epica but I gave you get more and more
often these days the London system so
how does he actually keep the center
intact let's chance check the quality
five is kind of vulnerable so Lee do
what are you doing yo let's take it this
might give white some compensation but I
don't really have a big choice that if
he gives me the e4 pawn I have to take
it basically and against the London and
this kind of this kind of direct
aggressive play is often just very
rewarding people who play these kind of
openings usually don't want that so
let's see you taking probably not i go
v6 so he might will might play a form
soonish how to play all you have to get
the Queen back anyway it's bound to be
hit by something an idea is 95 yep he'll
open up the c forum square here why go
away 693 will happen down i will go here
okay nights of for coming I wonder how
to play this my king is in the middle
and that's not so great but it is still
save on yay day you cannot quickly open
the center I just want to be ready to
take the mighty affinia and maybe going
to be seven at some cases yeah so it's a
bit
okay so the question is can I get g6
Bishop 27 and castles in without getting
completely annihilated if I can get it
in and fine
yeah I don't see much there for white
Bishop g5 Bishop g7 yeah it is it is
some pressure definitely but how serious
is it may be pleased Bishop b5 and 95
this could be something this is also
making lots of sense and try to win some
time gained some time I'm not sure I
want to take so I'm making a practical
decision just moving it maybe oh that's
a funky more interesting but ok I think
I can take and play Bishop g7 good yeah
of course but it's not such a big deal
um do I want to take yeah I don't want
the resulting position is pretty ok now
the sea porn is a target I've got my
king out of the center and half maybe I
should have not cancelled maybe not
from a six looked a bit problematic but
okay it didn't happen here i think i'm
just very okay to straining stuff I
don't know what to want to trade on
before really going to be to recurring
is one way of doing it but this is also
looking good good thing about this pawn
structure is very compact I mean it's
not easily getting at my pawns they're
all very nicely organized um shooting
forget five maybe here
yeah I think I'm okay hmm that it's also
Badree killing dr. move that comes
without a price tag queen bee to or i
can also do this ok f3 coming maybe
maybe look at three as something I'm
having can cover it with you gave a but
still it's possible these six is saying
NC three is hanging some can take stuff
now I just saw that maybe look at five
as a move I bet you can take with the
book but it's it's a motif to keep in
mind my king will actually quite safe i
believe so let's do this or I can check
and put this look in a pin yeah well
doesn't really let net-net much
so he wants to play book h3 threatening
loop takes h7 this is clearly the point
that's clearly the point and the h5 is
not kid not really convincing I take the
six I have to check their check on d5
time 183 all kinds of pins but I don't
believe it really ok ok after this there
are tons of pins going on I mean kingi 3
i'd check on g1 at f3 this Queen d2
check so he has to basically playbook f3
here or this work ok so maybe get the
points going now r this is this is the
idea
[Music]
okay he wants to come up all the way no
oh my god age 6 aah chak I was very
lucky that I had this no no I come on
unbelievable stuff I took it like wow
crazy times tremble at the end hmm yeah
there was stuff that was really really
tough yeah I think he even analyzed this
opening line somewhere with this with
this capture I don't quite believe that
white has enough there but there is
practical compensation for sure in a
blitz game 95 given by the engine yeah
this is maybe this is maybe a bit much
but I don't know I feel it feel is
fairly safe it's just slow
maybe I could have taken but it felt it
felt wrong to me I mean I'm already a
poor now I just need to avoid getting
killed maybe five is liked a lot by the
engine and then this move okay that's a
tough one that the tough moved to spot
before hand this is a week now this is
the thing yeah so maybe it seems I
should have taken adds up if you if you
spend a long time on those decisions you
always goes all time yeah this is just a
really good ending with the like having
the better structure it's mostly about
sending off the yeah the swindles let's
say that white rice there on the
kingside they shouldn't objectively work
okay and can engine controls that I
should just win but of course there were
some some crazy moment cai completely
completely overlooked the age six month
where was the aunty that handles and now
it was extremely murky of at the time
but okay you just have to play movement
movement yet at one point he just put
the rukon free like what was this was
this is this move yeah and i played at
five pre-move it's funny that the engine
just says equal I mean for connected
passes against the rook is not what you
see every day
I care okay it was funny that I had pre
moved I had pre-move Duke g3 and he
played Rock g3 with them so it was a
really funny pre-move and a good one
there because taking off the Rope means
I cannot lose the game anymore on time
okay thanks